businesses hit by a supply chain crisis
those who rely on our schools and our
hospitals and our police
they won't recognize the world that the
chancellor is describing
they will think that he is living in a
parallel universe
the chancellor in this budget
has decided to cut taxes
for banks
so madam deputy speaker at least the
bankers on short haul flights sipping
champagne will be cheering this budget
today
and the arrogance
after taking six billion pounds out of
the pockets of some of the poorest
people in this country
expecting them to cheer today
for 2 billion pounds given to compensate
in the long story of this parliament
never has a chancellor ask the british
people to pay so much
for so little
time and again today the chancellor
compared the investments that he is
making to the last decade
but who was in charge
[Music]
so let's just reflect on the choices
that chancellor has made today
the highest sustained tax burden in
peacetime
and who is going to pay for it
it's not international giants like
amazon
no the chancellor has found a tax
deduction for them
it's not property speculators
they've already pocketed a stamp duty
cut
and it's clearly not the banks even
though banker's bonuses are set to reach
a record high this year
instead the chancellor is loading the
burden on working people
and national insurance tax rise
on working people
a council tax hike on working people
and no support today for working people
with vat on their gas and electricity
bills
and what are working people getting in
return
a record nhs waiting list with no plan
to clear it
no way to see a gp and still having to
sell their home to pay for social care
community policing nowhere to be seen
a court backlog leaving victims without
justice
and almost every rape going unprosecuted
a growing gap
in results and opportunities between
children at private and state schools
soaring number of pupils in super-sized
classes
and no serious plan to catch up on
learning stolen by the virus
two billion pounds announced today a
pale imitation of the 15 billion pound
catch-up fund that the prime minister's
own education czar said was needed no
wonder madame deputy speaker that he
resigned
now the chancellor talks about
world-class public services tell that to
a pensioner waiting for a hip operation
tell that to a young woman waiting to go
to court to get justice
tell that to a mum and dad waiting for
their child to get the mental health
support that they need
and the chancellor says today
that he's realized what a difference
early years spending
i would just say to the chancellor has
he ever heard of the sure start program
that this tory government has cut
you voted for it
and why are we in this position why are
british businesses being stifled by debt
while amazon amazon gets tax deductions
why are working people being asked to
pay more tax and put up with worse
services
why is billions of pounds in taxpayers
money being funneled to friends and
donors of the conservative party while
millions of families are having 20
pounds a week taken off of them
madame deputy speaker why can't britain
do better than this